[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fan corrections this is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
real viewers watch the show try to find
mistakes so far there have been i don't
know like a hundred challengers not one
winner not one person has found us
making a mistake we don't make them
well tonight a fan with the youtube
handle mind controls says he thinks he
caught a mistake he says it happened
during my recent interview with reece
witherspoon
hey conan i got a rather embarrassing
mistake that you made you know where you
had a pathetic attempt to obtain a free
automobile here take a look by the way
this company this website is very happy
right now
that you mentioned them you're going to
get some free stuff
i'd like to mention porsche by the way
yeah well
it's actually pronounced porsche not
porsche
the german language doesn't use silent
e's so why don't you just go ahead and
admit defeat sorry
well mind control uh a bit of advice
before you address the nation you should
first always make your bed
do that first and then address the
nation i i have a feeling he wasn't
wearing any clothes either
most of our fans don't yeah
well mind controls you say
the german language doesn't use silent
e's
well old chum you're dead wrong the
german language does use silent ease we
have the proof check out this clip from
the german version of sesame street
seasons
[Music]
you will be silent
[Music]
let's screw it that guy all right the
challenge still stands if you think you
have spotted an error on our show
reported at teamcoco.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chuck
meat out of the maestro we'll take a
break